so let me start by saying i am a big fan
of your work and i want to thank you for
uh talking with me today
it's a pleasure steve
if um i like throwing some curve balls
at the beginning if someone has actually
never seen anything that you've done
what would you like them to watch first
the mission i think
oh yeah
that's kind of good
it's just kinda i'm joking it's very
good um when you were when you were
making the lion king and voicing scar
did you have any idea at the time that
the film was going to become
what it became this this massive film
around the planet
no i didn't i didn't i i i mean i did i
was doing working for the royal
shakespeare company at the time and and
i was just glad to be working in a
different meta i'd never made an
animated feature before and
uh
and the freedom that it gave me um
uh was
was enormous and we had huge fun they
encouraged me to
you know play around ad lib to find sort
of you know find qualities
which they would then go on and draw up
i'd always thought it happened the other
way around that the
the vocal artists uh you know put his
lines on a picture that was already
there but
that wasn't the way so um
i had no idea whether it would be any
good at all i think i was shooting house
of the spirits in portugal when jeffrey
katzenberg who ran disney at the time
rang up and said um i have to tell you
something extraordinary has happened
with scar he's um
he's actually become enormous as a
and and i thought oh that's very nice i
didn't say and will the check be in the
post
um because it was disney of course and
they only deal in
supermarket stamps i think um
but uh anyway the check didn't appear
but i knew they were very pleased and
and i then went on to see how uh what an
enormous
enormous success the film was i was very
proud of it
yeah as well you should be speaking
something else you should be proud of i
think that um watchmen the other two
years ago is is a stunning achievement
um did you have any idea it was going to
be so fantastic when you were making it
no i knew it was going to be
uh
extraordinary because
the writer the man who wrote it
was extraordinary an extraordinary mind
and
sitting with him at lunch when he first
started talking about it he talked me
through
my part of my area of the of the story
um i thought well this is going to be
something like something i've never seen
before i really want to be part of it
and
i was not disappointed when i saw it
finished
yeah it's fantastic um jumping into
house of gucci uh
more tremendous work from you um
ridley is a very unique filmmaker in the
way that he uses multiple cameras um and
he's a unique person on set can you sort
of talk about collaborating with him and
maybe what surprised you
well of course i worked with him on on
um
uh kingdom of heaven
about 20 years ago but that was a very
big film i didn't see a lot of him
because he was usually in some tent a
mile away with
one of the cameras always multiple
cameras which
make which is essential on a film of
that size on a film of our size more
domestic
uh
size although
he's i think turned it into a sort of
epic
tragedy uh with his with his style um
the great thing is having multiple
cameras i mean we had i think four
um
which
allows you to play a scene in a certain
way
and then do another take play it
completely differently and you don't
have to worry about matching
because it's all covered and that's in
enormously freeing for an actor
because if you are at the back of your
mind part of your mind is saying i've
got to remember this happened that at
that point in the scene or he said that
at this point in the scene and then when
you turn around to replicate the scene
you have to do it the same
this frees you up from that so that was
that was a great thing i found ridley
had
mellowed
in the 20 years
he's you know he's always been a pretty
taciturn northerner um but he's got
slightly less taciturn in those 20 years
he runs a wonderful set very calm
uh encouraging i mean
what he does he gets the best because he
knows the business so well he's ma he's
made so many films he knows the best
people the people he likes to work with
he also knows a lot of actors and he's
you know he i think he chose quite well
because he he got a group together who
who would work together as a family sort
of became a family
um and that's part of his talent
uh
but but but really what i thank him for
most is the speed
you know i filming is very laborious and
if you want to try to keep your
enthusiasm you'll bubble up
um it's very hard to do if it's really
drawn out it gets a bit like
drawing teeth at the dentist you know
you have a great scene with jared leto
at a table where he is showing you um
some of his drawings and jared really uh
disappeared into the role with his
prosthetics and the makeup and i'm
curious did you
did you meet
what was it like seeing that that um the
prosthetics and everything for the first
time and did you have any idea it was
him or did he try to play some sort of
game where he's like standing with you
and you have no idea it's him
no when he appeared i mean i knew that
was the person but i i i
i knew johnny was i hadn't met joe
before
so when he appeared i i thought it was
one of the italian producers
uh
and and then he started doing something
uh
he didn't do the actual lines that were
written maybe he was throwing in loads
of stuff and i thought this is
extraordinary
this is really extraordinary such a
brave actor to
to a change his appearance so much and
get within that i mean it's interesting
he said yesterday at the press
conference that he
as i do
loves mask work
and the way that masks can
um
actually show
[Music]
almost more an actor in a mask can
actually show more emotion often than an
actor without a mask and i think he felt
he was masked for that and it
created this extraordinary character
which when we'd finished the scene i i
was so admiring off i didn't know which
takes because he did things very
differently we'd use
um
but as an actor i had to
be ready for whatever he
threw out
you guys were great together i got to
stop there and i'm just going to say
congrats thank you so much for giving me
your time have a fantastic day pleasure
talking to you